the star power the looks
it's date night in hollywood just check
out the celebs
giving us all the feels lady gaga and
bradley cooper reunite with this warm
embrace
ah we're getting deja vu
now slaying the sag awards lifetime
achievement award winner helen mirren is
pretty in pink while wearing dolce
gabbana giving us life in a pant suit
elf fanning sparkles and gucci
and we can't forget this very fitting
look from the house of gucci star jared
leto yeah can you guess rocking satin
blue in head to toe gucci
and co-star lady gaga takes her breath
away in armani free day while jennifer
hudson stuns in a custom pink gown
now we love a relatable celeb selena
gomez ditches her heels while walking
barefoot on stage to present well here
we are selena the shag awards
uh martin
it's the sag awards
as for the trophies history was made
troy kotzer became the first male deaf
actor to win a sank award for his
supporting role in coda and the film
took home outstanding performance by a
cast now that you've made history you
were talking about
what it was like to live in your car
years ago
what would you say to yourself in those
moments when you might have been feeling
like
you're not sure that this is going to
work out i was a risk taker and that's
what my father always liked to call me
so i'm really glad that i took those
risks even though i have to admit it was
a tough journey but here's the payoff of
all that struggle so i'm very proud
staying on sag awards first squid game
became the first non-english language tv
series to win acting prizes and the
actor goes to joe hoyon
while will smith won his first sag award
for his role in the drama king richard
come on michael and michael keaton
almost missed his big moment due to a
bathroom break pretty stealth keaton i
could have sworn i had another 20
minutes i'm bad at this and we can't
forget about everyone's favorite coach
ted lasso jason sudeikis won his second
consecutive award and the cast won best
comedy ensemble
of course while the stars come together
ukraine was heavy in their hearts making
a statement on the red carpet a slew of
stars like tyler perry showed solidarity
by proudly wearing ukraine's flag colors
and during the award show brian cox made
his thoughts known while accepting
succession's guild award it's truly
truly awful
really really awful what's happening and
i think we should all stand together and
also for those people the people in
russia who don't like what's going on